argentina es un caso paradigmático
fijaos a finales del siglo 19 era el
país más rico del planeta es decir era
más rico que eeuu australia canadá o el
reino unido- en plena época del imperio
británico
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mediados del siglo 20 el país ya había
perdido algunas posiciones pero aún así
se mantenía entre los 10 países más
ricos y prósperos del mundo hoy sin
embargo no están entre los 60 primeros
como es posible que un país sufra
semejante decadencia una debacle de tal
magnitud pues tal vez tenga algo que ver
que desde los años 40 argentinas a
grandes rasgos prácticamente sólo ha
conocido a los actores dos corrientes
políticas los militares y el peronismo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en un pasado vídeo aquí en visual
político cuyo enlace por cierto os dejo
en la descripción y también en la
pantalla final hablamos del origen del
peronismo vimos como juan domingo perón
había llegado al poder cuál fue su
apuesta política y como en 1955 fue
derrocado por un nuevo golpe de estado
ahora bien qué ocurrió tras el golpe que
fue del peronismo cómo ha evolucionado
esta corriente política desde entonces y
tal vez lo más importante de todo qué
diantres significa que soy el peronismo
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 1955 se produjeron dos golpes de
estado contra el gobierno de juan
domingo perón en el primero que resultó
fallido la armada argentina llegó a
bombardear la plaza de mayo- con la
intención de acabar con la vida del
presidente
los transeúntes fueron sorprendidos por
la presencia de aviones que tenían la
presión oficial
[Música]
el segundo apenas unos meses más tarde
en septiembre de 1955 no falló
millares y millares de voces reclaman la
presencia del general lonardi y los
altos jefes en los balcones de la casa
de gobierno
contenibles la emoción cuando aparecen
ante el pueblo
[Música]
pero aún tuvo que exiliarse primero en
venezuela- luego en panamá y finalmente
en la españa de francisco franco con la
llegada del nuevo gobierno que proclamó
la revolución libertadora el peronismo
quedó literalmente proscrito todo
absolutamente todo lo que tuviera que
ver con la imagen peronista las marchas
los símbolos los signos los nombres todo
fue prohibido por el gobierno militar
[Música]
no hay vencidos ni vencedores solamente
un pueblo que marca hacia sus legítimas
tradiciones
en apenas dos años esta revolución
libertadora se encargó de desmantelar
todas las estructuras peronistas antes
de convocar nuevas elecciones incluso se
volvió a cambiar la constitución para
reestablecer la de 1853
eso sí agregando el artículo 14 bis que
introdujo casi todas las medidas
sociales e intervencionistas que había
establecido pero no
pero amigos la historia es difícil de
olvidar prohibiendo todo lo que tuviera
algo que ver con el peronismo en cierto
modo lo que el gobierno militar
consiguió fue convertirlo en una especie
de mito
[Música]
el caso es que en las siguientes
elecciones democráticas del 58 resultó
elegido presidente arturo frondizi un
político que trata de darle la vuelta al
rumbo de argentina y volver a abrirse al
mundo que es precisamente lo que les
había llevado a ser el país más rico del
mundo
pero espera hace un momento porque a
pesar de los buenos resultados
económicos enfrente tuvo a los
sindicatos peronistas y a los militares
que claro ya se habían acostumbrado a
jugar con argentina a su antojo si es
que una vez que la bota militar entra en
acción luego es muy pero que muy difícil
reprimir la tentación de utilizarla una
y otra vez el caso es que unos años
después los militares exigieron la
renuncia del presidente democrático
frondizi porque pues porque les daba la
gana os parece acaso poco motivo y como
el presidente no aceptó que pensáis que
hicieron los militares argentinos pues
mediante las armas le de pusieron y le
encarcelaron
[Música]
el caso es que poco a poco el ambiente
se fue volviendo cada vez más tenso y
los propios peronistas estaban cada vez
más movilizados exigiendo el regreso de
perón su líder hubo elecciones y un
gobierno muy frágil resultado los
militares volvieron a dar otro golpe de
estado por supuesto con otro nombre de
lo más poético cuestión de estilo ya
sabéis en este caso se trató de la
revolución argentina liderada por este
tipo que estáis viendo en general juan
carlos onganía
para dedicar la compañía
juro por dios nuestro cañón y estos
santos evangelios
con el cargo de presidente de la nación
aquí comenzó una etapa de mucha tensión
y es que además de la dictadura el
contexto internacional era de plena
guerra fría y en latinoamérica
generalmente eso significó luchas entre
guerrillas de izquierdas y gobiernos
militares y argentinas no fue una
excepción
y creo que podemos decir que los años 60
70 y 80 fueron terribles pero terribles
para toda latinoamérica en los
siguientes años en argentina empezaron a
surgir grupos guerrilleros y terroristas
como los montoneros el ejército
revolucionario del pueblo o las fuerzas
armadas del pueblo y ojo el propio perón
había dado un estratégico giro a la
izquierda y alentaba por aquel entonces
este tipo de movimientos desde su casa
en madrid que por supuesto estaba
ubicada en puerta de hierro una de las
zonas más caras de la capital de españa
[Música]
el caso es que entre la mala situación
económica y los atentados el descontento
era tal que el régimen militar se vio
obligado en marzo del 73 a convocar
elecciones al principio eso sí dejando
fuera a perón con la excusa de que no
vivía en argentina pero amigos hecha la
ley hecha la trampa
[Música]
en septiembre de 1973 se celebraron
nuevas elecciones y esta vez si juan
domingo perón fue elegido presidente y
su mujer isabel martínez de perón
vicepresidenta
[Música]
así más fácil todo quedaba en casa
el tándem presidente vicepresidenta
arroyo obtuvo una victoria aplastante
obtuvo aproximadamente el 60 por ciento
de los votos
pero amigos espera un momento porque no
iba a ser tan fácil atentos
[Música]
el retorno
tened clara una cosa en política y una
ley no escrita una cosa es la oposición
y otra muy distinta el gobierno y eso
mismo es lo que le pasó a juan domingo
perón
veréis como hemos dicho antes durante su
etapa en el exilio se convirtió en el
referente de todos los opositores a la
dictadura tanto de izquierdas como de
derechas pero claro la amistad entre los
extremos una vez caída la dictadura
estaba condenada a durar muy poco y eso
es amigos precisamente lo que ocurrió de
una forma además violenta
[Música]
y la situación se descontroló por
momentos la tensión era enorme los
grupos guerrilleros de izquierdas
continuaron atentando contra civiles
políticos empresarios y militares ya no
se conformaban con perón ahora querían
una revolución popular bueno al menos
así las llaman
[Música]
y el gobierno peronista respondió
impulsando la creación atentos de un
grupo paramilitar conocido como la
triple asociación anti comunista
argentina el resultado de todo este
cóctel os lo podéis imaginar tensión
miedo enfrentamientos y desapariciones y
por si no fuera suficiente además la
economía iba de mal en peor
[Música]
el regreso de perón estaba siendo un
desastre total y eso que duró poco
porque el 1 de julio de 1974 los días de
juan domingo perón llegaron a su fin
dejando a sus espaldas un legado
terrible en 1975 la guerra entre
peronistas bajo un gobierno peronista
era ya casi total y la crisis económica
terminó provocando una brutal
devaluación que dejó al peso por los
suelos
con este panorama aseguro que ya os
podéis imaginar lo que siguió exacto un
nuevo golpe de estado y no uno
cualquiera el día 24 de marzo de 1976 se
abrió el periodo más negro de la
historia argentina llegó al poder el
gobierno de la junta militar liderado
por jorge rafael videla cuya etapa al
frente de argentina se caracterizó por
la permanente violación de los derechos
individuales el cierre definitivo de un
ciclo histórico y la apertura de uno
nuevo cuya característica fundamental
estará dada por la tarea de reorganizar
la nación esta junta militar por ejemplo
dejó tras de sí la terrible cifra de más
de 10.000 desaparecidos y miles y miles
de presos políticos pero amigos esperad
un momento porque si pensáis una vez más
que el peronismo había muerto estáis muy
pero que muy equivocados
un nuevo resurgir
[Música]
tras el oscuro y terrible periodo de la
junta militar la democracia retornó a
argentina en 1983
[Aplausos]
iniciamos todos hoy
una etapa
en aquel momento los peronistas estaban
desmantelados y fue elegido presidente
raúl alfonsín a quienes los argentinos
recuerdan sobre todo por la
hiperinflación que se produjo bajo su
mandato muchos años de dictadura en el
país
e impidieron que quizás tomáramos
sesión de lo que es gobernar en la
argentina yo les pido disculpas a todos
por mis equivocaciones pero tengan la
seguridad que hay una pasión argentina
que me 9 ojo la inflación llegó a
superar el 80 por ciento mensual si es
lo que tiene darle sin parar a la
máquina de imprimir billetes y no sólo
eso además tanto los militares otra vez
como los sindicatos peronistas se
marcaron como objetivo hacer imposible
este gobierno así que los paros y las
huelgas fueron continuas y una vez más
ya reorganizados sabéis que volvieron
los peronistas en esta ocasión bajo el
liderazgo de carlos saúl menem y
sorpresa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el nuevo presidente tras dos primeros
años terribles dio un giro de 180 grados
y puso en marcha políticas totalmente
inesperadas por un gobierno peronista
sacó adelante una ola de privatizaciones
liberal hizo la economía y el comercio e
incluso logró la estabilidad monetaria
introduciendo el peso convertible uno a
uno con el dólar americano
de esta forma las inversiones
extranjeras se empezaron a llenar el
comercio crecía y los argentinos volvían
a prosperar y a sentir que podían
comerse el mundo pero amigos hubo una
cosa que el presidente menem no hizo
presidente macri tome nota reducir el
gasto público todo lo contrario el gasto
público se disparó y también la
corrupción y los derroches de todo tipo
[Música]
y no sólo eso como las cosas iban las
reformas no se completaron lo que dejó a
argentina con una moneda sobrevaluada un
gasto público enorme muchas
importaciones y una deuda descomunal
creo que al final todos sabéis lo que
ocurrió en 1999 la oposición se hizo con
el gobierno pero ya era demasiado tarde
en 2001 la crisis fue total
argentina incurrió en default y los
argentinos sufrieron el archifamoso
corralito bajo este panorama en 2003
seguro que ya no os sorprendéis los
peronistas regresaron al poder es
admirable la capacidad para escurrir
bultos para echar la culpa a otros que
siempre ha tenido el peronismo han
gobernado casi siempre pero
aparentemente nunca han tenido la culpa
de nada pero sabéis quienes llegaron al
poder correcto los kirchner peronistas
con las mismas políticas de siempre solo
que esta vez aún mucho más escorados a
la izquierda
[Música]
durante sus años en la casa rosada- a la
casa blanca argentina restringieron las
importaciones multiplicaron el gasto
público la inflación los impuestos y la
deuda si queréis saber más atentos a
este vídeo pero amigos un momento porque
antes de terminar nos queda una última
pregunta muy pero que muy importante
qué es el peronismo qué es el peronismo
cómo ha logrado ser casi hegemónico en
argentina a pesar de que sus resultados
han sido peor que malos estás son amigos
las preguntas del millón pues bien creo
que teniendo en cuenta la historia
podemos decir que el peronismo más que
un partido político es un movimiento con
dos pilares esenciales un
intervencionismo y un gasto público
desmedidos tenemos el peronismo siempre
vino a reparar a reparar la injusticia
al devolver la dignidad precisamente el
secreto de su éxito político tiene mucho
que ver con todo esto cada vez que
argentina ha tenido un problema los
peronistas han prometido más y más gasto
público todo por supuesto financiado con
el instrumento favorito de los políticos
populistas la máquina de imprimir
billetes
el caso es que bajo la excusa de la
soberanía política la independencia
económica y la justicia social las tres
claves establecidas por juan domingo
perón los peronistas han terminado por
hacer de argentina un país cerrado al
mundo con una inflación de largo plazo
bestial y viviendo prácticamente en una
crisis permanente así que me pregunto no
habrá llegado ya la hora de buscar otros
caminos pero ahora turno para ti cuál
crees que será el futuro de la
influencia del peronismo en argentina
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual política si
aún no lo has hecho por cierto muchas
gracias a nuestro amigo alejandro gómez
historiador argentino cuya ayuda ha sido
vital para la elaboración de este vídeo
pero ahora sí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]